Добиратися із Житомира до Києва
по часу може бути так само,
як добиратися з Троєщини
до центру Києва.
З Житомира ти можеш
за пів дня поїхати на зустріч,
зробити там усе
і навіть в обід повернутися.
Багато хто скаржиться,
що Київ витягує звідси таланти,
тому що 130 кілометрів від столиці.
Але ті, хто лишаєтся,
аргументують, що тут комфортно,
і так само за один день
можна отримати той самий досвід
перебування у Києві,
такого насиченого, культурного,
активного.
Майже в кожній сім'ї була людина,
котра тут або працювала,
або мала родичів, які працювали
на «Електровимірювачі».
Бачили, які тут класні кнопки?
Тут працівник як по алфавіту:
А, Б, В, Г, Д, Ж, З.
Працівники натискали клавіші —
і в них тут вилазили пропуски.
У місті якщо кажеш про «Вимірювач»,
то дуже багато людей питає:
«А що завод ще працює?».
Тому що біля заводу
побудований торгівельний центр
і всі думають, шо це вже ніби
«Вимірювач»
є частиною торгівельного центру якогось.
Завод «Електровимірювач»
основний вид діяльності —
це електровимірювальна техніка.
На основі цього там кілька років тому,
мабуть, з 10-15 [років тому],
був запущений напрям шкільного обладнання.
Це обладнання для STEAM-лабораторій,
для кабінетів фізики, хімії, математики.
І навіть 2–3 роки тому ми вийшли
на американський ринок.
Ми знайшли партнерів, які допомагають
нам просувати це обладнання,
і поступове зростання запиту
вказує, що ми на правильному шляху.
Окрім звичайної операційної діяльності
виробництва обладнання, яке випускає завод,
ми займаємося зараз створенням
інноваційного парку «Вимірювач».
Залучили команду людей, які
займаються створенням спільнот,
долучаємо фахівців електронної
музики, архітектури,
фахівців промислового дизайну,
і разом з ними створюємо щось нове в Україні.
Моє знайомство з «Вимірювачем»
почалося з дизайну фасаду.
Ми з Андрієм, власником заводу,
познайомилися на такому
замовленні,
коли він звернувся по допомогу
зробити проєкт-реконструкцію фасаду.
У нас була дискусія, що робити,
якшо орендодавець захоче вивіску на пів фасада,
і я кажу: «Ну це типу не хороше рішення».
Власне, у цьому діалозі з'явилася
ця дискусія про те,
що має бути інша цінність,
ніж просто квадратні метри
і право на будь-що робити з нерухомістю.
Не все, що старе, —
це те від чого треба відмовлятися.
Його треба трансформувати,
щоб воно було життєздатним.
Головне побудувати процеси,
які були б прості, прозорі, зрозумілі,
і які були б отим самим магнітом,
який б затягував сюди людей.
Вони, крім того, що мали можливість
тут щось створити,
вони могли б обмінюватися
думками з іншими.
Ну, знаєте, як у цій притчі, коли двоє
людей ідуть, в кожного по яблуку,
і вони обмінялися яблуками —
і  в кожного, як було по одному яблуку,
так і лишилося.
Якщо на місці яблук ідеї,
то до зустрічі у кожного по ідеї,
а після — в кожного по дві ідеї.
А якщо це 30 людей одночасно,
то ви уявляєте:
людина приїхала з якоюсь однією ідеєю,
а у неї вже суперспектр якихось думок, ідей.
І ми по суті прискорюємо розвиток
кожного винахідника, кожної людини.
Ну із цих пластин складається лампа.
Я їх буду зварювати між собою.
Я хочу попробувати простою зваркою,
котра напівавтомат, а не точковою.
І для цього маю розкласти спочатку
ці дванадцять пластин так, щоб…
Ну, так як мені підходить.
А потім подумати,
передумати і зробити все знову
точковою заваркою.
То цинк проводить от на ці дирки тепло,
і мені перепікає пальці,
тому я сьогодні в рукавичках.
Ставлення працівників...
Ну трохи вони насторожені,
тому що якраз більшість працівників —
люди, які працюють досить довго на підприємстві.
Тому для них це експеримент.
Притім, що вони також
залучені в цей експеримент.
Але вони дуже сприяють,
намагаються допомагати,
тому що всі розуміють,
що якщо нічого не міняти,
то це шлях просто в класичний сценарій,
коли підприємство закривається,
люди розпускаються.
І вони сприймають також цю трансформацію
як можливість переродження
заводу, переродження процесів.
І сподіваюся, що вони теж у цьому
матимуть своє місце.
— [російською] Оце можна зробити?
— [російською] Звичайно.
— [російською] А оце?
— [російською] А ось це, от так.
— [російською] Ось це в ручну можна.
— [російською] Це треба згинати.
— [російською] Шіснадцятками чи двадцятим.
— [російською] Двадцяткою, а що треба зігнути?
[російською] Така сама конструкція.
[російською] Та сама річ,
тільки з двадцятки зігнути спробуй.
— [російською] То, звичайно, можна зігнути.
— [російською] А двадцятим, оце фокус.
[російською] Ми можемо ще подумати над конструкцією,
якщо це треба, якщо ось так ми хочемо.
[російською] Відрізаємо і
підіймаємо з'єднання.
[російською] Ось так.
Тут знову 230, 230 виходить.
[російською] Розумієте, це складно, за один раз.
[російською] Це не просто поставив і відразу спіймав.
[російською] Нічого страшного, спробуємо просто.
Не вийде, то будемо намагатися ще раз.
[російською] Ну добре. Ми не проти.
[російською] Дякую. Я ж розумію,
що всяке може бути. Нічого страшного.
Ми багато працювали на Сході,
в дуже різних умовах.
Покинута будівля в центрі міста,
така величезна територія.
А тут місто близько до Києва.
Гарні об'єкти, приватна власність,
мені здається, що це теж такий один
із перших випадків,
коли є ось ця синергія або співпраця
громадських організацій і бізнесу,
у створенні спільного, а не просто
ось отримайте площу і щось робіть.
Ми зараз біля однієї з найстаріших будівель
заводу «Електровимірювач»,
яка колись була духовною семінарією.
Минулого року нам виділили тут приміщення,
які були насправді закинуті-закинуті.
Можна сказати, що це перша наша
така фізична окупація
і перше втілення інноваційного парку «Вимірювач»,
який ми задумали разом з власниками заводу.
І такий спільний проєкт — тут працюватиме
мультифункціональний такий об'єкт,
навіть як зараз:
люди собі працюють над якимись
своїми проєктами, об'єктами.
Ось тут у нас була школа,
і зараз відбувається Школа
предметного дизайну,
і виходить, що люди зараз
працюють над своїми об'єктами.
Троє хотіли займатися пап'є-маше,
одна людина доробила до якогось.
— Я шар здула, і це вийшов ящір.
—Ящір?
— Ящір.
— А це маска була?
Це мав бути торшер, але вийде маска,
тут можна її буде просто потім обрізати.
А ти пробувала підсвічувати її
зсередини, як вона на просвіт?
Ні, ще ні, ну тут ще трохи, має підсохнути.
Я думаю, що година, можливо, дві, і все готово.
Для нас школа — це є певний інструмент
тестування багатьох гіпотез, які ми собі ставимо,
і джерело ідей, які ми вбираємо для подальшої роботи
над ревіталізацією заводу загалом.
По суті переосмислити зараз завод,
переосмислити оце виробництво,
зберегти те, що цінне,
доповнити чимось новим,
зберегти цю тяглість,
яка, була ще, по суті, 1966-го року.
Завод цей — це дуже класне «нічого»,
хоча це величезне «щось»,
і тут є така кімната, котра
називається «неліквідна кімната»
і там зберігаються всякий непотріб,
котрий збираються викинуть.
Але це не непотріб,
я зайшла в цю кімнату,
і дуже багато всього [познаходила],
просто дуже сильно багато всього,
і там були оці пластини.
Я подумала, що це гарна річ,
і зробила з цього лампочки.
Ну не лампочки, а світильник.
Взагалі, завданням школи було,
наскільки я пам'ятаю, було те,
що треба зробити якийсь продукт,
котрий буде бажано тиражований,
і бажано, щоб це був предметний дизайн.
І це предметний дизайн,
це тиражована річ,
можна її робить скільки завгодно,
поки ці штуки не закінчаться.
Нам зараз дуже всім бракує якоїсь
фізичної роботи руками.
Все перейшло в цифру.
Я не знаю школи предметного дизайну,
яка містить у собі фізичну якусь розробку прототипу.
І зараз, мабуть, це єдина школа,
в якій студенти три тижні
щось роблять руками .
Тобто власне свій продукт
пробують створити руками.
Я спочатку думала про бетон,
але він дуже довго стигне,
а гіпс — ні, дуже швиденько стигне.
Додаєш туди пігмент, ставиш
варістори, як мені сказали.
Загалом, це конденсатори,
у них термін експлуатації,
мабуть, давно вже вийшов,
але в них дуже прикольна форма,
і вони червоні, і мені дуже подобається.
В мене дома зараз немає
можливості з майстернею,
і я пів року нічого не робила,
бо теж не було можливості
в майстерні працювати,
а тут просто купа матеріалів всяких,
різних, з котрими я не працювала,
і я можу робити що завгодно,
і це мені розв'язує руки,
я просто хапаюсь за все,
що тільки можна.
Зараз ми біля Яни і її прототипу,
Яна вирішила робити меблі,
не використовуючи зварки  і все іншого,
робити це такими збірними елементами.
[російською] Загалом така
конструкція, котра збирається.
[російською] Вона повністю з будівельних гайок,
ось таких продовгуватих,
[російською] індустріальний дизайн виходить.
[російською] І це може бути складеним
ось так у коробку.
[російською] У тебе може бути дві таких частини.
[російською] Наприклад, якесь плетіння, панно,
якесь сидіння, яке потім теж фіксується,
[російською] а потім ви берете його
і збираєте все це, тут.
[російською] Сьогодні ми намагалися зробити,
вже в реальних розмірах,
[російською] і у нас розірвало шпильку,
[російською] і не дуже все вдалося.
[російською] Але я буду
продовжувати.
[російською] Цікавий підхід,
що ви робите щось, ні з чого,
[російською] і я теж думала про це.
[російською] І розробка прототипу,
я ніколи не думала про розробку прототипу,
[російською] і це дуже класно,
[російською] що ви можете
зробити деякі дрібниці спочатку,
[російською] а потім втілити все це в життя.
Україна — це країна можливостей,
тут що хочеш, то втілюєш.
Ти в принципі можеш будь-яку ідею
реалізувати, будь-що.
Так, є менше впевненості у завтрашньому дні,
але по своїй роботі,
з досвіду я зрозумів,
що гроші, ресурс — це не є основна річ.
Його завжди є багато.
Питання, як ти ним розпоряджаєшся,
як ти його використовуєш.
Тема ревіталізації дуже
актуальна у всьому світі.
І переосмислення територій,
переосмислення виробництв,
воно дуже сьогодні прогресує,
дуже швидко змінюються технології.
І мені здається, що цей виклик дуже цікавий.
Я навіть переконуюся в тому постійно,
створюючи всі ці резиденції, проєкти.
Ти отримуєш від цього задоволення.
Просто отримати кошти —
я б не отримав від цього задоволення.